[Musica]
e poi non siamo neanche gioca di qua e
vediamo di tua come vi sentite a dico
dopo aver fatto una risata come vi
sentite magari quelli che hanno riso qui
ma magari quelli che non ce l'hanno
fatta
pensiamoci un poco dopo una grassa
risata come ci sentiamo bene per forza
perché è scientificamente provato che la
risata fa bene alla salute infatti
quando ridiamo in maniera bella grassa
aumentano le endorfine le catecolamine
sostanze che ci fanno sentire più o meno
così
diminuisce il costi solo l'ormone dello
stress aumenta nostri generazione del
sangue diminuisce l'aria residua nei
polmoni
inoltre quando richiamo la flessione
prima aumenta e diminuisce e tutti
sappiamo quanto faccia bene una risata
attenga nnnn
alla nostra psiche vero come ci sentiamo
bene dopo
ebbene allora vi faccio una domanda nei
vostri ambienti di lavoro come vi
sentite riuscite ad essere sorridenti
felici propositivi positivi a
collaborare sempre con i vostri colleghi
[Applauso]
più o meno la risposta è questa e non
parliamo del lunedì mattina signori e
lunedì mattina questo evento perché
ormai tutto un evento non lo sappiamo
ormai sui social
sappiamo che il lato vi partecipa
all'evento sto andando in bagno
sarà un evento non so per gli stitici a
questo evento per lunedì mattina che
suona la sveglia e noi rispondiamo in
due maniere la prima non ci voglio
andare
non ci voglio andare la seconda che tu
magari è passato anche una bella
domenica che ne so
torno in ufficio signori buona settimana
a tutti buon lavoro a tutti
ti guardano così come un alieno che
ormai c'è scritto nel contratto
nazionale del lavoro signori il lunedì
mattina è vietato andare al lavoro
felici è che tutta sta felicità che è
tutta questa libertà ma siccome sembra
che qui sono venuto così a dire papa la
teneva tanto così per ridere insieme
dico parliamone i dati in america il 23
per cento dei lavoratori soffre di una
sindrome che si chiama burn out
sapete cos'è stress da lavoro in maniera
costante il 44 per cento ne soffre in
maniera discontinua ma come è possibile
perché tutta questa gente sta male a
lavoro perché è chiaro che produrrà di
meno ed è chiaro che queste persone
stando 8 ore così però dovranno una
società infelice infatti altri dati ci
dicono ad esempio l'università di
warwick ha fatto alcune ricerche e ci
dicono che le persone felici prendono al
lavoro il 12 per cento in più mentre lo
psicologo sean è che ha evidenziato come
la versione felici producono il 31 per
cento in più e sono più accurati nei
loro lavori del 19 per cento
signori sono dati impressionanti sono
dati che ci fanno capire che la felicità
alla qualità della nostra vita è
importante non soltanto a livello
personale ma anche a livello aziendale
anche a livello di società tutta
allora mi sono chiesto ma come è
possibile che la gente appunto sia
infelice perché cosa dipende da che cosa
la felicità all infelicità magari
e il salario diamo qualcosa in più a
queste persone cine si è evidenziato che
non è così sia un picco di felicità per
il breve periodo della novità dopo di
che i successi la stessa cosa
ebbene signori io credo ma non lo dico
io che l'alienazione negli ambienti di
lavoro e le relazioni superficiali che
si creano portano a molta infelicità ed
è impressionante
signori è impressionante vedere le
persone nelle aziende hanno fatto che ho
visto con i miei occhi vedere queste
persone nelle pause caffè 15 minuti dove
uno può parlare con qualcuno scherza
reti rai una battuta è una barzelletta
sorridere perché non abbracciarsi e
invece lei di 20 30 40 persone che fanno
seduti accanto
ma cosa vai a cercare qui o macellai la
vita ma che cosa cerchi qua si va beh
non tutti saranno simpatici ma per
carità ma poi confrontarti è invece
signori siamo passati da un ti amo detto
quasi come dire con pudore detto che
checché che diventi rosso no diventavamo
d'orsi ma c'era molta molta poesia li
l'evoluzione della specie da lì a me ti
amo con una faccetta perdiamo faccetta
con gli occhi a cuoricino pende ebay me
e me macché ma se io sono felice di come
lo voglio dire agli altri siano lo
voglio abbracciare una persona che gli
avevo io comunicare con tutto il corpo
siamo corpo siano corpo non siamo numeri
è invece ci accontentiamo
sono felice t
sono molto felice sono infuriato ti ho
vinto al superenalotto
sto pregando
ma nel frattempo dammi 5 ma cos'è
[Risate]
noi ci fidiamo ma che cos'è signori
allora mi è venuta questa idea 15 minuti
signori 15 minuti al giorno nelle
aziende per cinque volte al giorno alla
settimana 15 minuti per fare in modo che
la gente riesca di nuovo a sorridere che
la gente riesca di nuovo ad abbracciarsi
sì perché no che la gente riesca a
riprendersi l'umanità che stiamo
perdendo ad essere felici felici 15
minuti al giorno signori perché va verso
una felice
torna a casa e crea una famiglia felice
è quella famiglia e un nucleo per fare
in modo che la società sia felice 15
minuti al giorno per dimostrare che la
felicità non è un miraggio lo so tutti
stai dicendo vado
insomma cioè non è che si può essere
sempre felice ci vuole un motivo
c'è bisogno di un motivo è venuto io il
motivo siamo vivi
non gli basta siamo che facciamo una
cosa tutti quanti insieme
ok facciamo una cosa 1 un respiro
inspirazione ed espirazione pronti anni
e un 2 tra via vai a casa cade possiamo
respirare
sapete che ci sono bambini che non
possono farlo se non sono se non hanno
delle macchine da lui dico per
esperienza perché li vado a trovare a
casa non si possono muovere non possono
respirare
se non attaccate a delle macchine e noi
vogliamo un motivo per essere felici 15
minuti signori per dimostrare che la
felicità dipende da noi non da cose
esterne
è troppo comodo e facile vediamo nella
cultura del lamento signore io mi
lamento mi lamento di cose esterne
quindi non sono causa di quelle cose mi
di expo a b li do wah quindi le cose
brutte non sono più causa mia
ma neanche le cose belle amico mio
allora ad o nelle mani di un altro la
mia felicità e signori non si può essere
felici al dove oggi se non abbiamo
questo il nuovo spazzolino l'energia
atomica una cosa pazzesca che quando lo
metti qua se vuoi essere felice se non
agiamo signori non puoi essere felice se
uno è questo quello nuovo
l'ultimo modello quello che si collega
più velocemente in permette di un
microsecondo e signori puoi vivere senza
quel micro secondo in più che utilizzerà
i per mettere lake city
[Musica]
signori 15 minuti al giorno per
rieducare ri educare alla felicità
tramite il sorriso come veicolo per
creare delle relazioni più belle
signori questa mela scrivete scrivete a
me lo dico che va potete scrivere tanto
ci colpì anche se il potere della risata
distrugge il potere distruttivo di una
sconfitta ve lo assicuro è così perché
quando tu riesce a ridere di qualcosa
che ti ha fatto male quella cosa non ti
tocca più è quella cosa crea delle
relazioni vere ve lo dice chi da 16 anni
fa clownterapia e mi son fermato con
patch adams quindi con il grande pace e
vi dico quello che si creano bambini
famiglie che stanno lì magari per anni
soprattutto in oncologia pediatrica e si
vedono arrivare uno stupido che per due
ore li porta da un'altra parte e questo
gli dà coraggio
ecco da coraggio vero e affrontare
quello che devono affrontare perché
sanno che c'è uno stupido che arriva e
ti porta da un'altra parte con quello
crei delle relazioni quello che ci manca
allora le cose che possiamo cambiare sì
o no ma qui adesso ora subito
mettiamoci tutti in piedi luce e luce fu
mai tutti i piedi va bene e benissimo il
tempo allora facciamo una piccola cosa
ci mettiamo una mano qui è un esercizio
di pace è una mano qui bene belle sapete
che facciamo chip assaggiamo felici
massaggiamo e sapete che facciamo ci
diciamo pure io mi voglio bene perché ci
dobbiamo voler bene
diciamo la voce alta non vi preoccupate
non abbiate paura vai io mi voglio bene
io gli voglio bene bravi e non basta
questo perché se io mi voglio bene fosse
questo questo bene lo posso donare a
qualcun altro
allora giriamoci verso una persona
adesso a sinistra fate voi di comunque
questo magnifico vai vai vai vai vai vai
chi sale acqua con un attimo dai che
sarà con dare un attimo una donzella
vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni
vieni vieni dai miami ma fregatene vieni
bravissima
ok allora vi chiedo e vi chiedo un
abbraccio signori quando parlo di un
abbraccio
non parlo di questo è e neanche di
questo ma che c'ha la tosse che gli
oppure di questo ma che è sporca che
quando parliamo di un abbraccio parlo di
questo è uno scambio do e ricevo se
riusciamo a farlo per 20 minuti si
rilascia un ormone che si chiama
ossitocina che l'ormone della felicità
vogliamo
ok questo è tua
ok grazie è ormai siamo fuori
[Musica]
fermi tutti finiamo con una grande
risata è quella che prima magari non
siamo riusciti a fare siamo pronti
richiamo di qua
e come quando siamo capiti allora tanti
123 a a
ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]